bonjour michel chalot bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec mon direct ce matin
sur rtl france alors l'éco taxe pourrait
être de retour il ya une dérogation
accordée à la région alsace c'est pas
une dérogation c'est une ordonnance est
une ordonnance qui traite en effet le
problème de l'écotaxe poids lourds pour
taxer le réseau alsacien
alors pourquoi justement le réseau
alsacien feraient figure d'exception
parce que ça a été une demande de la
part de nos politiques pour ont fait à
l'époque en l'idée à 15 ans après la
mise en place de la taxe allemande
il ya eu un report des véhicules sur le
réseau alsacien qui depuis en quinze ans
ça c'est quand même équilibré mais ils
maintiennent cette recette où ils
veulent maintenir cette recette est donc
taxer tout le réseau alsacien moyenne
2000 quand j'ai moi si je me trompe 2000
poids lourds qui circulerait non non il
ya là 909 sent donc pas 2000 c'est quand
même beaucoup
je sais pas qui a dit 2000 mais ça c'est
dans les comptages actuelle de toute
manière on ne peut plus compter on ne le
sait qu il ya plus de camions
côté allemand que côté français alors
vous quand on sait vous de 2,7 possible
réinstallation l'écotaxe dans la région
et le problème il est simple c'est que
ils vont taxer tout le réseau où il y à
plus de 900 poids lourds à dire il n'ya
pas que le réseau autoroutier
il ya tout le réseau des routes
départementales et nationales ce qui
représente à peu près 900 km2 voire pour
120 km de réseau no reçues et ça
représente ça veut dire que 85 % de la
recette sera mise sur le transport local
et 15% sur le trafic
11 quelle conséquence vous vous redoutez
bas ça sera un renchérissement des prix
de transport puisque c'est une taxe
version de l'infrastructure qu'on peut
estimer à peu près à ça et au final vous
dit que ce sont les consommateurs qui
paieront la facture parce qu'il paiera
jusqu'à dire qu'on se tire une balle
dans le pied
est ce qu'il ya une mobilisation qui est
prévu contre la mise en place de cette
écotaxe et est ce que vous craignez que
ça risque de revenir sur le tapis au
niveau national on verra oui au niveau
national c'est déjà revenu mais on parce
que ça concerne tout le monde qui
utilisera le réseau alsacien mais on en
est pas encore là on va commencer les
négociations avec la cellule quelle
quelle mesure vous préconiseriez parce
qu'il ya un problème dit l'alsace
justement de santé publique à cause de
tous ces camions qui viennent et qui
contourne l'écotaxe allemande via via ce
réseau alsacien
bon écoute lelia il ya en effet les
mesures qui sont actuellement placés une
vert d'ici à verdissement de la flotte
qui continue toujours et encore avec une
motorisation qui devient de plus en plus
propre des camions aujourd'hui le
produit pratiquement moins que d'une
voiture et c'est de continuer dans ce
sens là
le spectre des bonnets rouges vous
pensez qu'il pourrait reprendre le
combat
non les bonnets rouges étaient en
bretagne n'était pas fini chez nous
c'est plus des bonnets bleus on a
toujours été une région très je veux
dire et ordonnée il réfléchit donc on va
pas on n'en est pas là encore merci
beaucoup michel chalot de nous avoir
livré votre témoignage en direct ce
matin dans la matinale verte et france